have you helped your sister recover
after her almost burning down the gym
what happened so long ago I don't even
know I think it might be fixed now Jamie
Lynn Spears is back on TV and the
upcoming series on Netflix sweet
magnolias it is so sweet
so welcome back to TV jamie lynn and
welcome to ET but what was your what was
it about this show in particular that
made you say that's it that's how I'm
gonna make my return it was really
honestly one of those things that fell
into place I was I went into Netflix to
meet with to meet with about something
completely different and then as I was
talking to them they were like would you
ever consider doing um you know role in
a series on Netflix I was like yes first
off you need any job where I get to go
act and play pretend of course I want to
and then it was just by chance that all
the you know people who are the main
people to give you the nod if you can do
the show or not in East town and we were
able to have breakfast and it was kind
of like one of those things I fell in
love with the character I felt like I I
felt like I've been her in many ways and
I just kind of had compassion for the
character and I love the people who were
working on it and they took a chance on
me and I got to be a part of the show so
it really was just a big blessing in
disguise you said you wanted to build a
life with a mountain range she is
obviously the other woman but she is the
other woman with some baggage quite
literally because she's pregnant yes
okay so she's preparing to have a baby
with her new man who was formerly
married and has children so what we like
portraying
a pregnant woman what did you tap into
did you tap into your own experiences
there on that front well it was weird
because we've done this last summer and
last summer my youngest was only eight
year old and so I just you know I felt
like I just lost the belly and so I put
it back on but truthfully I like it adds
a whole nother dimension to her and it
was definitely different
I've never played any one pregnant on TV
but it's you know having to be conscious
about and aware of that and me as a mom
having a little baby I just think that
that even added more to my compassion
for her you know not only is she walking
around probably with the shame of you
know the whole situation that's falling
out but also now it's literally she's
wearing an undershirt and so there's no
hiding it so in a small town especially
I think that that was it kind of it
added a little bit more to the character
and I loved it and I kind of missed the
belly now it looked real the way they
dressed me made it really look real I
was really comfortable with it it almost
I forget sometimes that you know I had
my other little mother little sidekick
which was the belly and what was cool as
the show went on there was different
sizes to the belly so it was like the
first two episodes your insides won the
second - I was in a bigger size like I
really was growing on the show so I
thought that was really cool as well
doing this more oh did the girls fully
understand what it is that mom and dad's
Maddy fully gets it she completely
understands like you know it was cool
that I got a show on Netflix you know
like that was cool and I was like yeah
I'm proud of myself like the first time
I did something that like I Maddy he's
just sort of cool and um I would my mom
and Ivy actually came with me the whole
time while I was in we shot in Georgia
so the whole time we were there my mom
and Ivan with me and Maddy would come
back and forth with my husband because
you know she is a preteen with a full
you know softball schedule and all of
that so I would come there they would
come here and you know George's not that
far for me but it it definitely was the
first time because now that she's 11
it's the first time I was able to like
really talk to this look I know it
stinks but I got to be going for this
amount of time but we get to you know
think about all the good things that we
get to do when I'm home or whatever it
is so it's been it's been different but
it's nice she understands what's going
on around her how are you guys staying
in touch with everyone because you've
had birthdays to celebrate anniversaries
we have all been you know at a social
distance from other folks yes we did see
recently that Britney was in Louise
if I'm not mistaken yeah and that was
when this all first went down nobody
really knew or we still don't really
know what to expect from day to day so
when it first happened and we all kind
of thought week or two was gonna be what
was you know expected we weren't really
sure but as it got bigger and really
blown out of proportion Brittany's like
I wanna come home I don't want to be by
myself you know out here all her family
is pretty much here so she was able to
come home for like almost two weeks or
so she was here for my birthday and for
Ivy's birthday but then of course she
you know she has her children and all
that stuff in her home so she went back
to Los Angeles that's a couple of weeks
ago but again I think she went back with
the intentions of like this was only
gonna be another week or so and then
they added on more time so we're all
just trying to abide by the rules and do
what we're supposed to do and having our
family has been the biggest blessing too
and when we're driving each other
absolutely insane you know about things
you wouldn't normally get mad about but
also at the end of the day at least we
have each other you know and that's been
really fortunate as well you know some
people really don't have anybody to
warranting with and we do so I'm I'm
thankful that were here driving each
other crazy and I really thankful you
know that everybody's got be here back
and forth traffic away for way
I know right it's something that you
definitely have to be thankful for right
now even when your family's driving me
bonkers and someone's chewing too loud
or they're doing something else that's
just like exactly you have thank
goodness you and your sister are keeping
us entertained you obviously with your
tidbits from the show and with family
and some philanthropic things at your
booth we just offer but also I got to
ask you
Brett is especially candid on Instagram
does she run any of her posts by you um
no she just posts what she wants to post
and I think that that's what makes it I
think that's what makes it more genuine
you know like at times you know
especially when we're bored you know you
just kind of post what you feel like
posting and and uh you know it was fun
we've been able to do some good things
you know we did the do your part
challenge which was really awesome me
and her and a bunch of other celebrities
were able to give back and it was really
cool because when it started kind of
grassroots started my manager alexis was
kind of like look we got to figure how
we're gonna get back and literally like
I was online like picking out the things
to send to these people but until asking
them like what do you need what can I
help with and now looking at the amount
of time this whole foreign team has gone
down I'm just so thankful that we were
able to find a way to do something any
way that we could and help people so I
think that's what social media is in the
best course we can you know do silly
stuff like we all do but we also can
connect to each other and help each
other so I think that's been the biggest
blessing about social media yeah we do
still you take talk videos but we're
also trying to have fun and we're trying
to use it for something better as well
yeah absolutely
hi guys I'm in my gym right now I
haven't been in here for like six months
because I burned my gym down
unfortunately and I had to
and yeah one thing led to another and I
burn it down have you helped your sister
recover after her almost burning down
the gym what happened so long ago
I don't even know I think it might be
fixed now it happened yet something like
a couple months ago but you know I guess
working out and staying healthy is a big
part of it so it just seemed like a
relevant time to share information that
you hadn't recently you know had shared
before I guess yeah what resonated with
me how my mom's always like blow those
candles out when you leave the room oh
he's like okay we don't like handles in
our house because I'm not good with
candles my husband had an incident with
a candle in college we're like burnt
down his house or something so literally
we just decided like no candles
so I think that we can prevent any
future fires yeah I think you need to
tell your sister that too yeah
apparently right what area of the home
are you in chatting with us today um
we're in the study right now this is
kind of like where I try to like you
know try to disappear too but come here
but of course they always find okay so
this is like this is where we try to do
our work school work all that kind of
stuff
come here cater oh my gosh I'd be hi I'm
Rachel I love your pigtails
thank you I Perley hair so we have to
pull it back how are you guys keeping
yourselves entertained at home obviously
you've had school work what else are you
trying to kids entertained we've been
you know working out trying to just stay
active and my daughter is on a softball
team they have like a workout routine
that they all have to do which has been
good they've all stayed in contact with
each other about reaching their goals
each week and so I think that's
something fun to do set goals with your
friends or whatever it is and kind of
keep in touch with each other like I hit
this goal today or I hit that today or
what it could be simple I've been doing
that and basically just living outside
like I don't think we've been outside
this lunch since I was 10 years old like
I browse out on the swing sets running
around a lot of cooking I've eaten so
much I'm going to literally weigh 600
pounds but that's fine you know
like you got to keep your mental health
yeah healthy that's just as important as
your physical health so I would say stay
I'm active getting some sunlight and you
know just being creative with what you
can do and being okay with it not being
perfect that's that's how we've stayed
somewhat sane mostly yeah I know
all right we all have our day is that
it's for sure and I've also been busy
with some talks there as well and I'll
show you how to get it go right
honestly tick tock when I first started
doing and I'm not really like I don't
really know what I'm doing but
thankfully I have an eleven year old who
knows what she's doing very she doesn't
have her own tick tock but she basically
controls mine so she decides what videos
we're gonna do and we do it and
sometimes I'm dancing and sometimes
we're doing a little PSAs about you know
trying to make light of a heavy
situation so that's been especially for
your children I think it's important to
try to show them you know to find the
positive isn't some sides of this and
doing something like that was a fun way
for us to you know spread something that
was a little bit positive about this
whole situation and and you know my
husband thinks it's ridiculous she's
like oh my gosh you are wrong above what
are you doing won't you talk and I'm
like I'm having a great time and we gave
followers and we're connecting with
people so let's just you know we got to
learn to laugh a little bit tick tock is
fun enough I know I'm ridiculous but I'm
really good time so you gotta embrace it
and you gotta tell the hubs to embrace
it - he needs to get on the tick-tock
bandwagon with you girls
oh my gosh if I got him on there it
would be a bee it'd be really impressive
on my part
what are you and Maddie working on next
tick tock I don't know which dance was
it that you wanted to do next Maddie let
me get a preview young lady what's the
next one we definitely like to be
creative but we also like to do so many
dances she loves um oh oh this was huge
Charlie was me I know her name but I
don't want to say her own show I think
that she apparently somehow followed me
and swear to God that is the first time
my daughter was like wow
it's amazing it's the first time I
really like forget Netflix forgetting
anything that was the moment that my
daughter was really proud so that was a
week on I think that she's the really
popular one on there so we try to do
some of her videos too and Addison so
whatever they're doing we're doing just
not as good but that's who we try to do
our because you guys are nail don't
break my boyfriend and you're not saying
goodbye at elevation just yet you've got
a little reunion Zoey 101 well honestly
we you know it's something that you know
kept being brought up to me whether it
was on social media whether it was in a
you know formal way whatever it was and
for me I was like we can make this a
reality of course I want to do it you
know this would be great I love to Zoey
she was a big part of my life a big part
of a lot of people's lives and so we did
a mini reunion on all that with
Nickelodeon where I brought back one of
the sketches that I did while I was on
all that and the cast of Zoey came and
it was like old times I mean just one
big chaotic family getting back together
again and I was like we really should
make this happen so if everything falls
into place then I'm totally down for
Zoey you know it so a reboot of some
sort and hopefully everything can work
out and we can make it happen and I
would love to see where Zoey is and
where all her friends is and the PCA
gang so hopefully that will be something
that happens after all this quarantine
stuff kind of gets put to rest I know
right will we see it movie or a new
series literally like we are
these are baby conversations so we're
just trying to figure out what amy was
with the story B we want it to eat right
we don't want to you know just we don't
want to just do it is something that
just gets thrown away just to do it for
the sake of doing it so if we do it I
think it just have to be the right fit
right time I feel like I've grown up
with you as well and
so it's nice to see you just like
flourishing and growing into this
beautiful young woman and it's crazy to
see you now as his character who's a mom
to baby but I'm like does she's already
a mom in real life but it was weird
because like the last time I had really
done worked as worked as an actress was
as a child essentially um I think the
last time I really had like a scripted
role was silence maybe I was 1516 or
something so being on set as an adult
and then working around children was so
bizarre first off you don't have the
child labor laws on you anymore they can
work you all night if they want to know
gosh I miss those days and also just you
know seeing it from an adult point of
view working with children was like it
was completely different and it was nice
because I still loved it it was like I
still felt like a kid on set so it was
it was a weird it was so strange being
around kids on set and them getting
their score done and remember all that
so vividly actually just sit there on my
phone I'm like wow
nice to do any school work well I won't
said like I should be helping them with
their homework or something good to be
back oh it feels it feels great I was
why haven't I been doing this constantly
you know I think you know life has a way
of just you you know putting itself in
the right place the right time and this
was it this was the right place right
time I was so thankful to be able to be
a part of the show and I love it and I
want to do it as much as I can I think
any way that I can have my created out
creative outlet is where I want to do it
and I've missed acting and I'm just
happy to be back and happy to see what's
next and happy for everyone it's meet
Noreen I love her and just get to see
everyone in serenity because it's really
special and I love it now if everyone
else bill tea
[Music]